November 8 2016 was a good night for
Donald Trump I love this country thank
you thank you very much but it was also
a great night for marijuana California
Nevada Massachusetts and Maine all
approved legalization of recreational
cannabis in Florida North Dakota and
Arkansas legalized medical marijuana all
told more than half the states in
America have legalized the drug in one
form or another so how will the Trump
administration deal with pot which after
all is still illegal under federal law
on the campaign trail Trump seemed
friendly to the notions of medical
marijuana and leaving the rest to the
states I think medical should happen
right don't we agree I mean I think so
and then I really believe you should
leave it up to the states it should be a
state situation but signals from his
administration have been more mixed
there are still a federal law that we
need to abide by and cut in terms of the
medical you when it comes to
recreational marijuana I as you know am
dubious about marijuana
we asked cannabis industry professionals
what they see for the future of legal
weed in the Trumpy era I see the future
of marijuana industry under the Trump
administration as in the short term a
little cloudy but when I say cloudy
building the skies are dark it depends
is unclear I can never figure out
whether it's art of the deal or not you
know how much of its rhetoric and how
much of it is going to actually come to
pass I want a little more clarity before
I'm able to really give my opinion
Trump's Attorney General Jeff Sessions
is a longtime drug warrior but even he
seems reluctant to commit to a full-on
crackdown at stake I get can pass
whatever laws they choose but I'm not
sure we're going to be a better
healthier nation that if we have
marijuana being sold at every corner
grocery store attorney General Sessions
doesn't have to worry because that's not
how the industry works it takes a long
time to get either a municipal or County
permit
and they're highly regulated stores that
track seed the fill there's code you
don't open up nearest school the people
going into these dispensaries to
purchase such product has to be of age I
think the sitting Attorney General is an
older gentleman who grew up in a certain
context and we're all victims of her own
context in history so I understand his
position why he has those deep-seated
feelings you know marijuana is a cure
for opiate abuse give me a break
I mean you know this is the kind of
argument that has been made out there
just almost a desperate attempt to
defend the harmlessness of marijuana or
even its benefits I doubt that's true
much of modern science contradicts
sessions dim view of marijuana
therapeutic potential with the National
Academies of Sciences engineering and
medicine finding conclusive evidence
that cannabis is an effective treatment
for chronic pain after surveying 10,000
scientific studies on the matter
nonetheless the federal government
continues to keep marijuana in its most
highly controlled category schedule 1
and recognizes no currently accepted
medical use citing high potential for
abuse with sessions helming the
Department of Justice this
classification seems unlikely to change
anytime soon
meaning the tension between state and
federal law will remain when you look at
it being on Schedule one it's a bit
absurd because the definition of
Schedule one is highly addictive in no
medical uses and cannabis couldn't be
further from the truth on both those
criteria so at the end of the day the
truth is marching forward while
crackdowns on medical cannabis seem
unlikely given Trump's public statements
and overwhelming public support for
medicinal use
what about recreational marijuana after
all that's a distinction Trump's press
secretary Sean Spicer was careful to
make in his comment
the states where it's allowed in
accordance with the appropriations rider
have set forth a process to administer
and and and regulate that usage versus
recreational marijuana that's a very
very different subject with the largest
state and the Union legalizing
recreational weed the feds would need to
devote major resources to crackdown and
that seems like a fight most Americans
aren't up for either with 71% of
Quinnipiac poll respondents opposed to
the federal government enforcing laws
against marijuana in states that have
legalized medical or recreational yes
this disapproval of federal encroachment
on state laws is pretty consistent
across partisan lines I've always been a
believer in federalism and states rights
I think that is up to societies and
communities to dictate for themselves
what rules they choose to govern
themselves by hopefully moving forward
the administration will have an open
mind about it and be ready to listen to
see how beneficial this has been in the
areas where it's been tried if I were in
the in an elevator and had an
opportunity to speak Donald Trump
directly I probably invite him for a
drink or ask them to sit down over a
meal break some bread and give me the
opportunity to educate him about the
true data of the cannabis industry it's
a job creator
I'm not saying in favor of building a
wall but if you want to build a wall
there's potentially a couple billion
dollars worth of excise tax revenue I
don't see anyone pumping the brakes on
this big industry I see it expanding and
doing better and helping more people
[Music]
[Music]